Jenna Ortega will not be returning for "Scream
VII".
If it doesn't have anything to do with the
Melissa Barrera drama, then what's going on?
And what does it mean for the fate of the
movie?
Earlier this week, it was reported that Melissa
Barrera would not be returning for the currently
untitled seventh "Scream" film.
Barrera, who plays Sam Carpenter in the franchise,
was fired by Spyglass Media over social media
posts relating to the ongoing Israeli-Palestinian
conflict.
"Being famous isn't all it's cracked up to
be."
Barrera's dismissal from the highly-anticipated
"Scream VII" has proven to be controversial,
and left fans of the long-running slasher
series uneasy about the franchise's future.
Now, Deadline reports that Ortega, who stars
as Tara Carpenter, will also not be returning
to reprise her role.
The outlet notes that Ortega, who has emerged
as one of Hollywood's most in-demand talents
since her 2022 "Scream" debut, is leaving
the franchise to film "Wednesday" Season 2.
Ortega's decision reportedly has nothing to
do with Barrera's firing.
Her choice to call it curtains on "Scream"
was made months ago, according to The Hollywood
Reporter, though it hasn't escaped many that
the bombshell news comes in the wake of yesterday's controversial move.
"Scream 7" is still in early production.
In fact, Deadline says a script isn't even
ready yet — and Ortega has big plans occupying her schedule.
The "X" actress is heading to Ireland in April
to start filming "Wednesday" Season 2, and
needs to wrap up the decades-in-the-making
"Beetlejuice 2," which was forced to pause
production due to the 2023 SAG-AFTRA strike.
With Ortega and Barrera out of the picture,
it's unclear what a "Scream 7" would look like.
After all, the franchise made it pretty darn
clear with 2023's "Scream VI" that the Carpenter
sisters would be at the heart of the series
going forward.
"Sam?
You coming?"
It's sort of surprising that the "Scream"
franchise has found itself in this position
considering just how prominent the series
has been in recent years.
After remaining dormant for over a decade,
directors Matt Bettinelli-Olpin and Tyler
Gillett revived the slasher series with 2022's
"Scream," which saw the Carpenter sisters
teaming up with old guard Sidney Prescott
and Gale Weathers to protect the town of Woodsboro
from a new Ghostface.
The film emerged as a substantial success,
grossing over $138 million worldwide and proving
that the series could be relevant to Gen Z.
Paramount Pictures and Spyglass quickly produced
a sequel, releasing "Scream VI" to even greater
critical and financial acclaim earlier this
year.
The "Scream" franchise hasn't even peaked
yet, but it seems as if its wings are being cut off.
"Happy Death Day" series director Christopher
Landon was roped in earlier this year to direct
the upcoming "Scream VII," but it's unclear
when production on the seventh outing will start.
For Ortega, however, this is a major strategic
move.
The actress has turned into a superstar since
"Scream," and it makes sense that she wants
to double down on "Wednesday," the Netflix
series that turned her into an overnight horror
icon and an Emmy nominee.
While the "Scream" franchise has always been
great to her, they were never really her projects
to begin with, unlike "Wednesday," which is
clearly a showcase for her talents as a lead star.